making his third major league start nate
pearson the number one prospect in the
blue jays system that according to
baseball america and scouts say that
he's got the best pure stuff of any
pitching prospect in the game so the
marlins hands full tonight and that'll
bring brian anderson to the plate
and he sends one high in the air to deep
left field goriel turns around looks at
a three-run blast
for brian anderson marlins jump out to
the early lead in a three-run home run
for brian anderson brian connects for
the fourth time and picks up rbi's 11 12
and 13. it's three to nothing marlins
here in the first bases are loaded for
eddie alvarez looking for source big
league rvi has a great shot at it right
here pitch number 65 on 3-1 is outside
alvarez gets the rbi on the basis loaded
walk and it's four-nothing marlins looks
like it's going to do it for
nate pearson
one of the top pitching prospects in
baseball wasn't overly sharp in this one
jacob waggis pack is into the ball game
his fifth of the year
sierra ground ball and knocked down by
guerrero does he get to the back in time
he does not
the wheels of sierra
get the marlins a fifth run i mean are
you kidding me he was flying down the
line and even went to the leg first
slide feet first slide so joyce scores
to make it five nothing it's an e3 on
guerrero marlins still have the bases
loaded and here is vr and that one gets
away from janssen marlins are going to
get another one well fair to say things
are getting away from the blue jays all
right here's aguilar 0 for two today
base is full of marlins two down on one
one a swing and a miss throw down a
second by jansen and vizio was way
behind the back at second base and
coming home to third alvarez the marlins
just stole a run now you've got runners
at first and second two down
two two to aguilar is a line drive into
right field for another base hit
coming around third racing to the plate
sierra throws into third base and out at
third base jonathan br looked like the
run scored first though five runs on
three hits
eight nothing the marlins over the blue
jays here's t oscar hernandez
hit high in the air to deep left field
and this looks like a no doubter for t
oscar hernandez
blue jays are on the board now trailing
eight to two over number five for t
oscar and he got a pitch up around the
letters and he didn't miss it there's a
lot of time for this club to come back
he got a string hits together so
britchick is aboard with one out and the
batteries rowdy teles who struck out his
first time up
and this ball is crushed
rowdy toles hits one a mile to right
field for a two-run shot
hey you never know plenty of time left
for roddy that's home on number two and
this was a big time over
he got that high fastball and he squared
it up second and now it's a four-run
game the marlins have an 8-4 lead
they've scored eight runs on six hits
francisco seville's been up twice walked
twice scored a run
hits a ground ball to the left side into
the hole it's short up with it pachette
long throw in and out of the glove of
vladimir guerrero jr at first base
that'll be e3
well another base is loaded at bat here
for vr we've seen it already what two or
three times he's squared to bunt with
the bases loaded
oh no bunt there base hit into right
field that'll score cervelli
everybody goes station to station nine
to four on the rbi single from jonathan
vr here's aguilar who's one for three
here's the pitch and it's slapped the
other way down the right field line
that's in for extra bases perhaps home
to scores alvarez
and behind him is bernie the throw goes
to second and he's out at second the
marlins are going to tack on two more on
the single for jesus aguilar travis
shaw's the batter
and now travis shaw sends a fly ball
pretty well hit to deep left field and
it's gone
opposite field two-run homer for shaw
his first as a blue jay and the 100th
home run of his career and it's 11 to 6.
travis shaw with an opposite field shot
the 100th career home run a milestone
for travis shaw 11-6 miami here's danny
jansen a fly ball and a base hit
1-0 here's a swing at a high fly ball
out to deep left field that's headed for
the screen and goodbye
it's their fourth two-run homer of the
night jansen with a home run it's 11 to
eight
so one down on the bottom of the seventh
and that'll bring up vladimir guerrero
jr glad he's had a tough night he is
over three at the plate and he has
committed two errors in the field
a fly ball to center field
back is sierra it's gone
it's not a two-run shot but it's a solo
home run for vladimir guerrero his
second on the season
the fifth home run of the night for the
blue chase and it's
11-9. vlady jr gets in on the fun his
second home run of the year is a shot
and the blue jays trail 11-9
blue jays trail the miami marlins 11-9
beau bechet who's four for four
but here's a fly pole and beau beshette
his fifth hit of the game
and he has joined the home run crowd
what a monster night for beau buchet and
the blue jays are within one for the
first time in his career and we were
going to say this again he has a five
hit game five for five for bishop his
fourth home run of the season and the
blue jays have homered in six straight
innings travis shaw has one of these
home runs tonight right now you're in
the minority if you haven't hit a home
run tonight and shaw drills one to deep
right
and he has tied the game
second of the night for sean the blue
jays have come all the way back
what a game the jays were down eight to
nothing probably thinking about the off
state of martyr but the players just
hung in there they kept battling they
kept swinging and i guarantee you both
the shed was in the middle of that
dugout said hey fellas we got a lot of
game left and one and two the count on
magneris sierra
and sierra right center field gonna fall
a two rbi single for sierra and the
marlins back in front 13 11. that'll
bring jesus aguilar to the plate sierra
the runner at third this would be a
really big run wouldn't it here's the
pitch
and it's sliced down into right field
that's going to get down to drive in the
run and the marlins lead 14 to 11. 14 to
11.
guriel is the tying run one ball and two
strikes
here it comes a one-two pitch swing and
a miss
wow it's a marlins win and the marlins
wrap up 23 days on the road they end
this road trip in first place partner